and I want to thank my mother I want to
thank my mother I'd like to thank my
mother pick my mom thank you mom thank
you mom thank you mom thank you mama
estas party my mother I love you I love
you mom so I'd to thank my mom
especially my mom my mom my mom my mom
mom my mother my mother be my today my
mother who did craft services for the
film uh who's the most brave beautiful
woman I've ever known the greatest woman
on the planet is here tonight that's my
mother Ruth my mother honking rats
mother the most beautiful women here my
mother Blythe Danner who I love more
than anything my mother taught me to
write taught me that um all of my finger
paintings were Picasso's thanks to my
mom for always encouraging us to try to
make art for believing me from the
beginning I made a life for me where I
got to be a part of nights like this I
don't care what they say about bringing
you to award shows I will always bring
your award shows cuz I'm proud of you
and I love you you've sacrificed so much
for me to be able to live here and make
my dreams come true and there are no
words to describe how much I love you
one thing my mom was giving me the
strength to fight every single day to be
who I want to be and give me the courage
to dream that this dream might be
happening and possible for me I love you
mom so much so mom this one's for you
Sokka poor poorly with this tonight I
honor you and the moral of the story is
listen to your mother
you
[Applause]